The following is a production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Legend of Holography.
Hello, this is Frank Defradas, and welcome to HoloTalk, the Internet Laser and Holography Talk Show.
Our toll-free number is 1-800-4583525, where you can send an email to Holotalk at HoloWorld.com.
We've got telephone calls, we've got emails, we've got special guests coming up.
So thank you for tuning in, and let's get this week's show on the road.
Hello, everyone.
Frank Defratus here with another week of Holotalk.
This week's guest is Derek Gallan from the Royal Holographic Art Gallery in British Columbia, Victoria, British Columbia.
And Derek's going to fill us in on some of the aspects of his gallery there in Canada.
And it's also going to give us a look into the new red star emulsions that are coming out of Russia, which hopefully will be able to replace the agile emulsions that are becoming very hard to come by for doing holograms.
Just an announcement.
Every year we pick a new project.
This project is going to be reconstructing the Titanic holographically.
What we're going to do is take archival film footage and bring it into the laboratory and create three-dimensional holograms from the archival film footage that was shot on the Titanic expeditions.
So if you tune in next week, you'll be able to get details on that.
Now we're going to put up a separate web page for this whole process.
There's going to be a number of people involved with it, including local students and some students out of the Philadelphia area.
And we're going to take you step by step through this entire process.
You can do this on your own if you're at a home studio because everything that we're going to do is going to be done with homemade equipment and your desktop computer.
So even if you don't want to do a hologram of the Titanic, you may have a hologram that you could do of some video footage that you shot, maybe a wedding or the birth of a baby, or a birthday party, or anything of that nature, a holographic portrait using a camera.
And we're going to take you step by step through this entire process and how you can make one of these holograms on your own.
Of course, the project that we'll be working on will be the Titanic footage.
So you just have to replace that information with whatever type of information you'd like to do with the hologram on your own.
As a sidebar to that information, the student who will be heading up the other students, sort of like the manager of the other students, will be Julie Rosner in the Philadelphia area.
And Julie is a student who has been working with me since she was in the second or third grade.
I first met Julie and her brother Ross at my laser and holograpes at the Franklin Institute in Philadelphia many years ago.
She continued to come up to the studio and learn about holograms.
I've worked with her family with several science projects involving holograms and lasers.
And she's going to be heading up the students for the Titanic Project.
Next week we'll have an interview with Julie so you can get to know her a little bit better.
And if you're a student listening to this this week and you're on a holiday vacation, you certainly want to tune in next week, which will be the 28th, the week of the 28th, and hear a little bit about Julie and how she's going to be working on the project.
Our musical guest this week is a group called Mitchief Piven.
Mitchith Piven.
And they are out of Ukraine.
Now, my daughter and I used to do cybercasting of concerts, and we went down to the Philadelphia area and did a cybercast of this concert.
It translates, I believe, to Dead Rooster, and they're a very, very popular band in Ukraine.
So they're going to be our guest tonight, and you'll see a separate link on the HoloTalk page for them because we do the musical broadcast in 288 while just for the voice broadcast of Holo Talk itself, just to keep the file size smaller.
This comes to you at 14.4.
So after the show, don't forget to click on the link and listen to the music that we recorded it live in Philadelphia of Mitchiv Piven.
Okay, we're going to move on right away to the interview with Derek from the Royal Holographic Art Gallery.
After the interview, Derek sent an email to me saying that you know how it is when you get interviewed, you always forget to say some of the things that you want to say.
And he said, just to give an example of how popular holograms are in his area of the country, that they've had four break-ins at his shop and had holograms stolen.
So people are taking a heck of a risk to get in there and take holograms.
That's incredible.
So let's move on to the interview.
It lasts about 15 minutes, and uh the Royal Holographic Art Gallery also has a link on the Holo Talk page.
And if you want to, remember you can also listen to the interview while you travel over to the web page itself, which is www.island net dot com slash Tilda Royal.
We'll take you right there.
Or just click on the link.
So let's go to our interview with Derek and see what he has to say about holography in Canada and also the new red star emotions which are coming out of Russia.
We're talking to uh Derek Gallon from uh Royal Holographic Art Gallery in Victoria, British Columbia.
Why don't you tell some of the listeners what they could find in your gallery if they were to visit your shop?
Frank, we try to have as much of uh as possible of different artists on a different hologram products.
We try to find uh new products, we constantly search for them.
That's the reason we are able to show uh quite unique Russian holograms.
We started uh the partnership with uh Russian holographers more or less uh three years ago.
We have a constant display of uh Russian holography.
Uh made mostly on a Russian glass plate, which is kind of difficult for shipping, but they are extremely high quality as you know, and they are very interesting.
So we have like uh one wall devoted only to Russian holography.
Most of it is like uh old Russian artifacts from uh museums, but there is uh few modern art pieces.
Quite uh interesting display I would say.
Uh the other holograms we have are uh Larry Lieberman's uh multicolor holograms.
We have some of the holograms from uh Holland from uh Dutch holography studio and uh we have the photopolymers which uh Hughes made uh once using very well known masters from uh Mr and Mrs Olson as well as uh Mr Cherry.
So they are quite uh good I have a number of those myself.
They're incredible holograms on the photopolymer materials.
That's really sad that they are no more available on the photopolymer.
Mm you know that's the bigger pieces and then we have plenty of uh smaller holograms from uh many many different studios from all over the world as well as the holograms we make ourselves.
So there's uh something for everybody.
Just something I would like to uh especially point out is that the traditional use for uh some smaller holograms like uh for gift industry it's uh kind of uh limited in your opinion.
It's uh you have uh trinkets, you have pendant keelings and uh wall pictures, watches and that's that's more or less it.
So we try to show people uh new ways of using holograms.
So we mounted a couple of uh larger film pieces uh in the floor of our gallery on uh mounted directly on the wall so it looks like a part of the wall like looking through the window.
It's uh quite a simple trick but it gives uh extremely good effects and people are stunned by the look of those holograms.
Yeah you have a lot of these holograms on your website, don't you?
Uh website is like uh my uh hobby too.
I just love uh working on the internet, I love creating home pages.
So yes, we have a quite large uh website and uh most of the stuff we have uh pictures online, that's right.
But some things you can see only at the gallery.
If we have just uh one or two pieces of something we usually are not putting it on the net.
Let me just remind the listeners that you can visit the Royal Holographic Art Gallery website at www.islandnet dot com slash tilde royal slash index dot HTML and we will also include a link directly to the site on the whole talk page and while you're listening to this interview you can click right on that link and go over and visit the site because the real audio player will continue to play as you go place to place on the web.
So there's no need to sit there and stare at your computer while you're listening to this click on the Royal Holographic art gallery link and go over and visit the site while you're listening to the interview.
Yes that's exactly what I did when I listened to uh interview you had uh last week with uh hunter from China.
Oh okay.
It was extremely interesting interview and uh we are very impressed with the hard work those guys in China are putting up to promote the holography in China.
But there is a something interesting.
You know there is a hunter in China said that many people is like uh experiencing holograms for the very first time.
Mm-hmm.
We are in Canada.
It's like uh, you know one of the leading countries in uh high tech, but still we have uh quite many people coming to our gallery saying that they are seeing holograms for the very first time.
No kidding.
Yeah.
Isn't that something?
Questions you can uh write a separate book about that.
You're also getting involved with um Russian emotions as well for holographic artists to use in their lab now that Agva has sort of crapped out on us.
Could you tell us a little bit about the uh Red Star film that well we are using already this film to create our own stock holograms.
So this film is already existing.
It's uh very high quality film.
Just we have uh some uh final uh problems we have to solve before uh bigger distribution of uh this emotion of the film.
We had some problems with uh upgrading uh light sensitivity and uh now we are almost ready to ship out the first uh samples of this film.
Actually we are I would say ready it's just with the Christmas rush we have to hold down and just uh finish uh south of uh stock existing holograms to uh different uh hologram stores as we are wholesalers of our own images and uh simply after Christmas lush it's over we'll uh start distributing the first samples of uh red star uh holographic film.
Let's let's hold for a minute on the uh the sensitivity of the emulsion.
How close are you getting?
Uh because I would say that Agsa is sort of like the benchmark of where people are used to doing an exposure.
How close are we with the Russian emulsions to that sensitivity?
Are we getting pretty close to that now?
I'm not sure about the very well known Slavic uh company which is trying also to develop uh films.
But what we are having in partnership uh as a joint venture with a couple of uh Russian labs it's uh well we had some problems with uh very high sensitivity.
It was uh very strength problem in a large volume we had a problem with the emulsion which was kind of too soft and uh having problem drying it up properly.
So I would say that we have a very sensitive emulsion but it's at this stage it's simply not ready for a big rant.
In a small amount it's uh possible to manufacture that in a big lance it's it's it's it's uh it's kind of half and we cannot offer it yet.
What we are the closest uh to agha I would say is uh what we have now is like a half of the AGFA sensor it's uh not bad but we hope for more soon.
We are working on it hard.
I think a lot of philographers have the tendency to overexpose for reflection holograms anyway.
I I know I give sometimes up to twice the amount of exposure that Agva recommends whenever I issue a reflection hologram.
So I think that's pretty close to uh to being accepted.
You are on the release so you will get the samples too and then you will be able to evaluate yourself.
Okay.
You will like it.
How about the processing?
Is the processing now much different than what you can do with the Ag for emulsions?
Uh the processes processing we use is uh quite different.
It takes up to ten minutes to keep it in a developer.
Really?
Yeah.
It's closer to just a regular black and white film developing.
Mm-hmm.
It's this way.
Without bleaching it's just uh closer to photography.
No bleaching.
That's amazing.
Who would have thought that you could ever produce a reflection hologram without bleaching.
I believe you saw some samples of what we have and they are quite bright.
They are very bright.
Yeah.
Yeah I think with the red sensitive emulsion people who have thirty five mill heanies they're not too concerned about it.
But you know there's a ton of five milliwatt lasers out there.
The people do this as a hobby as amateurs.
It's hitting them pretty hard because they just I hear you don't have that stability, you know, to have that long of an exposure time.
So it's uh anything that can get close to what we did see with AGFA is good.
Now you can also produce images for other people.
Now does someone send you a laser transmission master which is duplicative.
So we can start it from scratch.
Like uh right now we are just working on a special custom order for Oklahoma State University and uh it will be eight by ten film hologram five hundred copies.
Mm-hmm.
So we are working on sizes up to eleven by fourteen right now.
Prices are nice too I understand.
Well it's I would say less than half of uh regular prices for such a surface.
But I believe that you Frank deserve uh to have uh your own interview as well.
Like you are interviewing some other guys, but what you did lately with the photogram, as I understand you you were able to improve the quality, finishing the mastering touches with with uh digital equipment and I saw some uh samples of uh final results they are much better than you they used to be.
So I believe uh somebody has to call you one day and uh do an interview with you.
Okay, well that's that would be interesting to do.
Yeah, the digital aspect has increased the quality quite a bit because we were working from thirty five millimeter film.
And anytime you take that up to any large size, you know you're going to get grain and you're going to lose your resolution.
But once that uh film and image has been digitized, uh once you have that digital information you can do just about anything you want to with it.
You can even sharpen it up and rework it and things.
So that that is a big jump.
Excellent.
Now I will remind uh listeners that the photogram is a technique Frank developed so simply anybody can just uh make a pictures using regular camera and of the negative film Frank is able to create the three D hologram.
We had them and they were quite nice.
So that's something which is very interesting.
Thank you very much.
Anything else you want to let our listeners know before we head out for this uh I just would like to thank all the visitors on the internet.
Visitors to the side.
We have uh quite a good traffic and uh quite uh big uh demand for holograms.
The newsletter we have online.
Yeah, that's right.
You have to have a newsletter now.
Tell us a little about the newsletter.
Oh, it's just the short sort of uh monthly emails with some updates like in the new edition will be inf information about uh closing out by uh Hughes.
You know, just uh little facts of uh holography community as well as some uh basic information about holography and uh processing used in holography.
It's just like uh, you know, a little short newsletter with introduction.
Your feature artist is I think Sharon McCormick.
Yes, still we have Sharon on and uh there will be uh new guest in uh probably next couple of weeks.
Again, after Christmas Rush I will have more time to to finish the new page.
Actually after New York tell us who it is.
Uh we are working give us the scoop.
Hello.
It'll be about Ruby.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
And uh whole page will be changed.
Uh I'm working on a new image of our page.
Mm-hmm.
It's always because uh when I visit your page I feel ashamed that I'm always behind you and I try to get closer.
When I'm closer than you do I move and I'm back again, so actually I'm so impressed with your page, like you it's uh every time I visit it goes up and it's kind of better and better.
I have no idea what it is.
It's just really just a simple thing.
It's just a simple thing.
Sharon McClormick's going to be on the show, by the way.
She's going to do an interview.
I'm really looking forward to having her on the show.
Super.
It's not going to be until probably fall, I would imagine, 'cause the show's booked now until the end of September of ninety eight.
Oh wow.
Which surprised me, but I'm happy that that happened.
So Sharon's gonna be a guest on the show toward fall.
She's on vacation right now, I believe she's in Baja.
Or maybe I shouldn't say where she is, I don't know.
Yes, uh we hope to have uh her exhibition in Victoria, BC sometime next year.
We are working on it too.
Okay.
Well, Derek, thank you very much for being on the show.
And I hope you get a lot of traffic on your page from uh listeners to Holo Talk.
Are you any specials right now?
Oh yes, we have like a whole seasonal uh like uh another half of a page promoting uh I would say fifteen the most popular holograms and hologram products.
Do you have any more readers?
No.
You know we are thinking about creating some similar holograms to make over the Russian uh partners.
You know, I had a reader and it was stolen.
And then I saw that you had a few, and I got one from you.
Mm-hmm.
And it's one of my favorite holograms.
I think it's so neat.
But I put it somewhere so that it would be safe and I cannot find where I put it.
It's gone.
It's around here somewhere.
I don't know whether I put it in a book like in uh in an encyclopedia book and put the book back on the shelf.
It's gone.
I can't find it.
So Monday I'm gonna have to go through everything and see if I can't find my reader hologram, 'cause that is one of my favorite holograms.
I love that hologram.
Yeah, it's a nice piece, small but nice.
Yeah.
All right, Derek.
Well take care.
What time is it out there?
Uh we just have uh 15 after seven.
Oh, okay.
All right.
I didn't keep I didn't keep you up.
Take care, and thank you very much for being on HoloTalk.
Thank you very much, Fred.
Okay.
All right, take care.
Take care, thanks for there we have the Derek Gowan interview from Royal Holographic Art Gallery.
I'd like to thank Derek for agreeing to be a guest on the show.
And also thank all of the other people involved with the field of lasers and holograms for agreeing to be on the show for the 1998 year.
We are booked until the end of September, and I will try my best to bring you interesting programming every week so that if you have a computer and an internet connection, you can just log on and hear about the field that we all know and love, which is the field of lasers and holograms.
I imagine we have a lot of new listeners this week.
I'd be willing to bet that there were a ton of computers under the Christmas tree.
And more than likely they're set up and they're running now towards the end of the week.
So if you're a new listener and you've just joined us, welcome, and I hope you continue to come back and enjoy HoloTalk every week as well.
Don't forget, on the twenty-eighth, and for the entire week of the twenty-eighth, we're going to be announcing our nineteen ninety-eight uh holography project here at my own personal studio.
And that's going to be uh the reconstruction of the Titanic holographically from archival film footage that was shot during the expeditions to the Titanic itself.
I will back that up with some web-based material.
So, anyone who may be an amateur or hobbyist philographer and have some equipment on your own, you may want to try this.
So, Debbie Lee will be back next week.
She asked me to wish you all a happy holiday season if you happen to celebrate the holidays this time of the year, no matter what holiday it is.
And myself, I'd like to wish you the same thing and have a safe one, and I hope that you have the opportunity to share it with loved ones as well.
So this is Frank Defrates for HoloTalk, and I'll see you next week.